tu as aussi murray 11 ans est l'un des
meilleurs archers du département dans la
catégorie benjamins les 106 au club de
guyancourt le sportif a débuté le tir à
l'arc à sept ans après avoir testé le
judo le handball la natation et le
tennis
alors pendant les grandes vacances je
m'ennuyais de mon grand-père m'a fait un
arc
donc ben ça m'a plu et après la rentrée
j'ai décidé de m'inscrire
ça m'a plu donc j'ai continué je me
retrouve ici
malgré son jeune âge le palmarès du
prodige déjà bien remplie tao a été
champion départemental de tir en salle
en janvier dernier l'arche a également
terminé quatrième aux championnats de
france le 28 février
une ascension éclair qui déboussolent
son club quand il a commencé le tir à
l'arc
c'était quelque chose qui lui plaisait
énormément déjà à l'origine mais c'est
une vraie pile électrique
c'est à dire que i l'armée ait tiré une
arme et il tirait il a réitéré
et voilà il n'était pas dans là j'espère
lilas au fur et à mesure des années il a
développé la gestuelle mais non je
n'aurais jamais pensé que qu'il en
arriverait là jour j'espère beaucoup
pour viser encore plus haut tas au
centre n 7 heures par semaine et
participe à trois compétitions par mois
objectif prendre part aux plus grands
rendez vous sportifs mondiaux aller aux
jeux olympiques
pourquoi parce que c'est ce qu'il ya de
plus ce qui est plus au niveau sportif
donc c'est intéressant mais avant de
penser aux jeux olympiques sa prochaine
compétition est programmé le week-end du
14 mai à orléans
l'athlète s'alignera sur deux départs le
guillon courteau espère une nouvelle
fois monté sur la plus haute marche du
podium